[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back uh to
our coverage of the 2023 US national
championships yes we have Fabby as our
new National Champion but the ladies
competition up for grabs there but we
have a very special guest in studio Nick
regon Nick you're with Ascension I am
welcome welcome welcome welcome here
love being in here I do a lot of
interviews all year for the central
Charity Classic and lots of other stuff
work but this is the one I enjoy the
most every year really yeah fantastic
that's true I'm not lying it's good uh
tell our viewers uh about Ascension sure
uh you know the viewers um know me I've
been on this many times but essentially
we're the largest hospital system in the
country we have 150 hospitals in 20
States we serve tens of millions of
people every year particularly in the
the most vulnerable parts of the
community where we're the safety net
provider and we're really proud of that
Legacy and uh and I've been with the
Sensa for 10 years and it's a calling to
work work in in health care in a
Catholic Healthcare System to help the
most vulnerable is really something
you're called to do and I'm really proud
of the work we've done Nationwide now we
don't have any hospitals here in St
Louis but we're headquartered here and
because we're headquartered here I
thought it was really important that we
have an impact on the community and so
we've done that through our charitable
giving including with the chess club and
the Ascension Charity Classic golf
tournament and other stuff so I'm really
proud of that Legacy and we're very
grateful as well and uh thank you for
that and then you know uh through your
son you help the the Ferguson school
district and bringing chess into the
schools as well so again thank you for
that tell us a bit about the charity
tour centor Charity Classic this is our
third year we're a PJ tour Champions
event so we're partnered with the PJ
tour which is the professional Golf
Association and we started this event
three years ago really to invest in
North St Louis County you know the rest
of the country still thinks of St Louis
or North St Louis county is Ferguson and
what they saw on TV a decade ago and
it's much more than that and so we
created this event all the proceeds stay
in North St Louis County to the Urban
League Boys and Girls Club Mary Grove
and um and I'm proud of saying year
three now again this is a professional
golf event we're both the most
charitable event on PG tour Champions as
well as the best attended we've had
record attendance our first three years
over 50,000 people and so uh I'm really
proud of that that's a reflection of St
Louis our ability to give back uh the
commitment of our corporate sponsors to
be engaged and and I think you know it's
it's covered live on the Golf Channel
for 3 Days the Charity Classic and it's
Love Letter to St Louis it reminds the
rest of the country that St Louis uh is
not what you remembered from Ferguson
from 10 years ago but rather it's a good
a great place to work to live to play
and the state of Missouri has invested
heavily in it our Governor Mike Parson
our Lieutenant Governor Mike kho um our
big Court corporate Partners have and I
think it's become uh a part of the
permanent Sports landscape the way the
blues and the Cardinals and soccer
NASCAR and chess and golf are part of
that landscape congratulations for that
that you man I think St Lou is very
happy for and very grateful for
everything that you are doing for the
community and I want to ask specifically
about Chess because you've been
instrumental in creating your uh move
chess program right which is for the
underserved students is an after school
chess program tell us more about it sure
so uh about eight or nine years ago now
I can't remember the exact timing but um
it was born of my son at the time was in
fifth grade and he was at community
school and he played a lot of Chess and
he said to me appropo nothing you know
do all the schools in this area have
after school chess and I I don't know I
no idea uh but it it got me to thinking
and this is right after Ferguson and uh
so I made a call to the chess club and
Tony Rich picked up the phone and I said
hey you know do do all the and he goes
no in fact we just got a new
superintendent Dr Joe Davis uh at
Ferguson and he he likes chess and he'd
like to have a program and I said what
would it cost and we started talking
numbers and I went downstairs talked to
my CEO and he said let's do this and the
next thing you know your move chest was
born and we've done a bunch of
fundraisers and I think we raised over a
half a million dollars for the program
and I think it you know and it's been
six seven years now and you could see
how it's impacted the lives of these
kids and it gives them more confidence
the ability to to think on their feet uh
to know that decisions have consequences
and so I'm just so proud of that you
know I believe that chess has its kind
of Curative power um to make people more
whole to heal them it's a game we could
play for life as is evidenced by you um
and uh and so for a long long be great
at a Long Level uh and so I'm really
proud of that and I'm proud that that of
what the chess club and particularly Rex
his vision for chess in St Louis
Scholastic chess and you know I'm proud
of the fact that when I travel and I
tell people I'm from St Louis they
usually ask about the blues and the
cards but a lot of people say wow isn't
that the chess capital I say absolutely
I like to joke that with a with a little
vision and a lot lot of investment you
could create something very special and
Rex has done that I'm really proud of it
yeah you're so right um you're also the
captain of your chess team the Ascension
chess team in the corporate league and I
know you guys haven't won
anything you said that
such said that
enthusias new new new captaincy coming
is there any chances that we could get a
get a better captain in the years ahead
I I think we have better captains um in
the waiting um we we have a very
enthusiastic team I will tell you the
corporate chess league and um and what
Alex is doing yeah it's amazing at at
how much that has created uh with the
companies that are part of it how
competitive it is and Lauren's been a
big part of that and um they have a
great team of Edward Jones does and dhy
solutions and others and and we love
Enterprise is the champ an Enterprise
yeah that's true we have a new champ I
got to I got to bring you into the into
the mix here look this is a very
important game Karissa Yip she has a
half a point lead coming into the
competition she's playing white beum uh
half a point behind her now you got this
nice Knight on the Square
D5 uh two Bishops for black but look at
this the king is going to need to Castle
by hand G6 King G7 now you're white in
this position you just played the move
Bishop B3 are you
confident that your position is good
enough for at least a draw oh yeah for
white yeah so what I what I'm not that
anybody would ask me but I like that
Bishop back there I'm worried about that
Knight on C6 so I would open up yeah I
would open up that I would open up that
pawn the a pawn just so that it has a
retreat Square okay you like that you
like that maybe although I see the other
Pawn is I mean the other Bishop the
black Bishop is looking at it anyway so
yeah that might not be the best move no
no I mean the position I'm worried about
that Knight jumping in though the big
question that I really meant to ask you
about this position is uh basically
Karissa has a choice she has a choice
that she could Castle short put the king
away tuck it away there very safe option
or go long and make it a com game yeah
right that I would go long all the way I
mean come on but come on you point lead
yeah that's true the safe place to
Castle Shore just and make black come
after you way back and do a lot of
nothing make black make a mistake you
got to play the tourn that's why I'm and
not a grandm I would Castle long and
then just making an all out slugfest
Nick you came in very very enthusiastic
talking about Magnus Carlson and what
was going on qar with the watch what's
your take on that whole controversy know
I think um I have two points of view one
is it it it's good that people are
paying attention you know Gotham talked
about it when he did his recap when it's
Magnus and cheating it it gets double
the views right and that's good for the
game I wish I wish that we would just um
there'd be less emphasis on the acram
mats that go with it more on the game
itself it was a brilliant game I think U
Magnus himself said he didn't think it
was cheating but having a analog watch
threw him off somehow he's the greatest
player of all time I don't think Bobby
Fisher well actually Bobby probably
would have gotten thrown off too I don't
know if you would have or Gary would
have or others Bobby would have stormed
out actually um it's interesting there's
so many good young players and Magnus
not being the world champion it's a
little weird it's a weird feeling for
all of us like it's not Magnus the world
champion and I think he's adjusting to
life after being champion and being more
of a streamer and doing a lot of other
stuff and his streams are interesting
but um I don't think he loves classical
chess the way he used to and I'm not
sure he's quite as sharp as it used to
be uh we're seeing that actually too
Kate we're seeing that the um online
chess has changed dramatically we had
Wesley on earlier he's saying on the
scales he's earning as much playing fast
chess as he does playing classical
chessar earns 10 times people want to
see that action they don't want to wait
2 hours for a player to make a move so I
understand that it's kind of speeding up
the game when you think about the
broadcast here from these US
championships you're watching the
highlights you're not watching the four
hours right it's hard to watch the full
I mean I I watched the highlights I um
you know I go to Gotham and get some
updates and and then I go and play like
we want to go play I like online I love
classical chess but it's it's boring to
watch hours and I'd rather see you know
especially even with a minute time
control with increment watching a car
Magnus there's usually a decisive
outcome there's sometimes you get draws
but there's way more decisive outcomes
that at the end of the day the Casual
fan like myself we don't want to see
draws we want to see decisive outcomes
and the shorter the time control the
more likely you're going to see a
decisive outcome the longer the time
control the more time they think you
know they're making stockfish level
moves EXA less likely there's going to
be a decisive outcome and so I think you
know as more and more people get engaged
on the sport through twitch and YouTube
through Gotham through hikaro through
Daniel and others um they want to see
those shorter time controls because we
want to see decisive outcomes absolutely
Nick thank you for joining us thank you
for everything you do thank you for
supporting CH St Louis chess club the
world h of Fame cheers to Ascension and
your CEO well thank
you when we thank you I was going to say
yes when we going to play little Blitz
oh yeah baby bring it you been afraid of
me oh yeah you know I'm done black I'm
tricky I play the Scandinavia I'm very
trick I've been ducking you for quite
some time absolutely thank you Nick and
uh let's just take a quick look at our
standings uh we're going to